foreign
everybody I hope you're enjoying your
end of Year celebrations hope you're
having a merry Christmas and a happy
Hanukkah I hope you're rolling into New
Year feeling good hope you're uh not
putting on too much weight and not
adding to the regrets right before you
make all the New Year's resolutions I'm
Dave Rubin and what we are doing today
because I've given my guys the week off
and God knows what I'm doing right now
probably changing diapers we are doing
our top 15 craziest political moments of
the year the zanious the wackiest the
weirdest the most confusing most bizarre
etc
etc and uh well here we go number 15 you
may remember this one from a couple
months ago AOC protested at her own town
hall in her home District people have
had it with the AOC
[Applause]
listen
oh my God I'm used to talking and
everyone listening to me I hate when the
little peons get to talk to me
like that AOC lady Don Lemon was on
Stephen Colbert and this one was a doozy
the word on the street is that you guys
aren't allowed to be liberal anymore is
that is that the case I don't think you
ever were liberal what yes I don't think
we've ever worked not me saying that
that's the people out there saying that
he's not letting you be liberal anymore
well I listen I think that I think what
Chris is
saying is that he wants Republicans
sensible Republicans he wants us to hold
people to account but he wants people to
come on and feel comfortable with coming
on and talking on on CNN and appearing
on CNN so if you invite someone in your
house you want to make them comfortable
but also but by the nature of what we do
we have to hold people to account and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going liberal or conservative or
whatever it just means that we are doing
what we do and that's good journalism
God that clip first off Don Lemon you're
not a journalist secondly of course you
people are left or liberal or whatever
you want to call it thirdly the way you
talk about they have to be decent
Republicans you know they have to be
these moderate Republicans what you
really mean are neutered Republicans and
why would you never say that about
people on the left that sort of factory
setting mentality and doing it on the TV
show of Stephen Colbert who's a Democrat
activist who was making fun of unvaxxed
people for two years it's all just gross
you guys get it next up was a this was
actually a really really bizarre uh
moment and and something that I think
changed uh sort of the course of Sam
Harris's career Sam Harris the the
well-known atheist I would say a former
friend of mine someone who had been on
the show many times was a clear thinker
for quite some time but I think got
really banged up with Trump derangement
syndrome and made some mistakes along
the covid train and nobody gets any of
it right he had this very very bizarre
moment on a podcast that the internet
was not happy with I don't care what's
in Hunter buy them so I made a hunter
buying at that point Hunter Biden
literally could have had the corpses of
children in his basement I would not
have cared right it's like it's there's
nothing first of all it's Hunter Biden
right it's not it's like it's not Joe
Biden but even if Joe like even whatever
scope of Joe Biden's corruption is like
if you if we could just go down that
rabbit hole endlessly and and understand
that he's getting kickbacks from Hunter
and Biden's deals in Ukraine or whatever
else right or China
it is
infinitesimal compared to the corruption
we know Trump is involved in it's like
it's like it's like a firefly to the sun
right I mean like there's just it
doesn't even it doesn't even stack up
against Trump University right Trump
University as a story is worse than
anything that could be in in Hunter
Biden's laptop in my view right now
that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York post's twitter account
like that that's a just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted right and I'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not Simon I'm sorry that particular
piece I'm really sorry I was the one
that's God that's harder to watch now
than it was than realizing how much
collusion there was and that we are now
finding out all sorts of stuff related
to the laptop and the FBI and what was
going on at Twitter and that dead
corpses in his basement versus Trump
University and I mean just all of it
subsequently Sam ended up once Elon got
Twitter they got into a little spot and
Sam deleted his Twitter account and I
think Sam disappearing and I take no joy
in this I just want to be very clear
about that
um Sam leaving Twitter I think is a is a
major blow and get and getting so many
any of these big things wrong is is a
major Blow To The Atheist movement that
he really built in America he was
Central to it for for a good decade and
there basically is no atheist movement
left anymore I personally think that's
probably a good thing because the people
that caused many other people not to
believe in things uh well I don't think
they realize that perhaps Sam didn't
realize I think Jordan tried to explain
this to him people need to believe in
something one way or another so they end
up believing in many cases in this woke
craziness so the non-woke atheists
actually fed the woke Machine by
destroying Faith that's a whole other
story but anyway Sam isn't even on on
Twitter and Twitter anymore so that was
a weird moment for the internet uh here
was one uh you may remember we put this
one together this was two evil snake
people two of the worst of the worst
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
in California governor Gavin Newsom who
were together and we we did this in one
take I want to be clear we did this in
one take hey I'm Justin Trudeau and I'm
so excited to be here because I'm in
California with another lizard person
he's a lizard person just like me and
I'm here with him in California which
he's turned into a communist [ __ ]
just like I'm trying to do to Canada
we're both World economic Forum Stooges
but we have really nice
suits look at our seats and look at his
hair I just love him so much oh look at
him look at you I and I'm getting used
to look at me I smile when I'm talking
so people think I'm a nice guy but
actually I eat babies yes I do I love
them they're delicious and I'm always
eating them and then I use their blood
as gel in my hair it's very exciting for
a guy like me and I'm very happy to be
here with Justin Trudeau who is so evil
that makes me look like a good man yes
isn't it true Justin yes yes it is true
yell it you're just so cute I just love
you so much think about all of the
people we could lock in their homes and
freeze their bank accounts it's very
exciting for both of us I'm so happy
about it aren't you happy about it gab
it's just yeah oh yeah yeah love it
ah love it love it
next up was uh Julie Behar on The View
used to like Joy Behar she lost her mind
and then this Ukraine war broke out and
the poor woman's gonna have to delay her
vacation again 50 000 ukrainians will be
dead or wounded yeah and that this is
going to start a humanitarian crisis a
refugee crisis in Europe we're talking
about five million people that that are
going to be displaced I mean it's it's
heartbreaking to hear what is going to
happen yeah well I'm scared of what's
going to happen in in Western Europe too
yeah you know you just you plan a trip
you want to go there I want to go to
Italy for four years I haven't been able
to make it because of of uh the pandemic
and now this you know it's it's like
who's gonna what's gonna happen
that clip like
it's such a perfect example of the
myopic world view of these people it's
sunny I'm no fan of Sunny Athen 5
million refugees a human catastrophe I'm
trying to go on vacation I would like to
eat risotto in Italy God these people
they're just terrible but there are
worse people than even the women on The
View it's true uh this is number 10 you
may remember Elizabeth Warren after the
Roe v Wade Lee came out and everybody
was freaking out they're not going to be
able to have abortions we want our
eight-month abortions we want our
post-birth abortions Elizabeth Warren
made this this might be the the most
insane by uh by a sitting politician the
craziest thing that was said by a
sitting politician lawyer just listen to
the way this woman really really wants
to kill as many babies as possible and
doesn't want to give anyone the
opportunity to get help in case they're
questioning what they should do relative
to their pregnancy
in Massachusetts right now
those crisis pregnancy centers that are
there to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help
outnumber true abortion clinics by three
to one we need to shut them down here in
Massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country
you should not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
but you should be able to kill as many
babies at any point in the gestation
process as possible I mean the idea that
you're fooling people into bringing life
into this world and you know when that
video happened we were in the midst of
of pregnancy with our surrogates and it
was like we wanted these babies these
healthy
babies to love and bring into our family
so badly and it took so long and all of
those things and then the way that she
thinks she's good when she's so
profoundly evil you must admire it at
some level
number nine the elderly man pretending
to be president was shown up at the
White House by the other guy that he
used to work for
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that visual right there like Obama with
that [ __ ] eating grin and he doesn't
care about Biden at all and he's just
using him as the empty dementia ridden
suit to get his policies across you know
when someone's touching your shoulder
and you certainly know when someone's
touching your shoulder when you're
Barack Obama because they don't just let
anybody touch your shoulder what a
dismissive perfect sort of metaphor for
exactly what this presidency has been
all about but speaking of that number
eight
Dylan Mulvaney this is a man with a
penis who pretends to be a woman was
invited to the White House to interview
Joe Biden and just to be clear once
again we did the research don't ask how
we did it I don't even want to know what
you Googled but we did it was unclear
when we first showed this video whether
Dylan had a penis or not Dylan has a
penis enjoy do you think States should
have a right to ban gender affirming
health care I don't think any state or
anybody should have the right to do that
as a moral question as legal question
the Mind muddled Joe Biden nobody has a
moral or legal question can decide
whether you should chop your genitals
off I decide I'm Joe Biden
here's an ad from Evil Lizard person
Gavin Newsom I can't believe we put
Gavin on two of these things number
seven go it's Independence Day so let's
talk about what's going on in America
Freedom it's under attack in your state
Republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors I urge all of you
living in Florida to join the fight or
join us in California where we still
believe in freedom freedom of speech
freedom to choose freedom from hate and
the freedom to love don't let them take
your freedom paid for by noon the gall
of that man to pretend that he cares
about Freedom who had the most Draconian
lockdowns and all the mandates who has
destroyed the city that he once was the
mayor of San Francisco and now destroyed
California that he dare talks about
Freedom every one of them we went
through it and we played the video
originally every one of the bullet
points that he lists out there are
complete lies they're all distortions
and he's going after DeSantis because
DeSantis is the standard bearer of
what's right in America he's the
standard bearer of what's wrong and
perhaps in 2024 we're going to get that
match up number six uh this was not a
great moment Joe Biden getting to Israel
and butchering the Holocaust I will once
more return to the hollow ground vashem
to honor 6 million Jewish lives were
stolen in the genocide
and continue which we must do every
every day continue to Bear Witness
to keep alive the truth and honor of the
Holocaust part of the Holocaust honor
those we lost
honor of the Holocaust horror of the
Holocaust you say potato I say potato
what are you going to do we could not do
a top 15 list however without showing
you something from the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and obviously
we had over 400 billion I counted them
single-handedly 400 billion clips of
insane things that were said on MSNBC
over the a year but I felt that this was
the completely craziest one you may
remember this we played it a couple
times Joy read on the Uvalde shooter who
killed I think around 20 kids and a
couple teachers it was absolutely
horrific and listen to Joy's take there
was no mental health issue with the
individual who stole the futures of 19
children in Uvalde Texas
no mental health issues by default lady
if you kill 20 children 20 innocent
people you have mental health issues but
what she really wants to do is make
everything political so she wants to
make it about the gun that the guy used
that the gun is somehow inherently evil
but you know what good people with guns
don't shoot people same people with guns
don't shoot people unless they're trying
to defend themselves or their property
or their loved ones Etc it absolutely by
the very definition of what he did was a
mental health issue and also Joy you
have a mental health issue and speaking
of mental health issues one guy who had
a mental health issue but I think it's
probably a little less now because he's
since been fired Brian stelter Mr Potato
Head got the boot from CNN
America needs CNN to be strong I believe
the Free World needs to CNN to be strong
and it will continue to be
because all of us are going to help make
that happen
[Music]
the Free World
needs a reliable source
so four reliable sources for the last
time I'm Brian stelter thanks for being
with us
okay now get the [ __ ] out
I think we added that part
that's good I didn't know you were
throwing that in that's good uh stelter
was an absolute embarrassment and
especially if you think about in light
of what we've now learned about the last
few months of misinformation related to
covet and Russia and everything else
like that that he sat there on a show
called reliable sources pretending to be
the good guy and then of course the
footnote to his story is he gets fired
in shame from CNN and what is his gig
now he's teaching journalism at Harvard
you cannot make this stuff up just
incredible one thing that you shouldn't
make up in general also is that you have
say cancer but of course Joe Biden
managed to do that here's number three
and guess what
first Frost you know what was happening
it had to put on their windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why I had so damn many other
people I grew up have cancer and why
can't for the longest time Delaware had
the highest cancer rate in the nation uh
fortunately look he's the president I'm
glad he doesn't have cancer the funny
part about that really is that the man
says he has cancer and virtually
everyone was like no no no no don't
worry it's not the president has cancer
it is it's that he has dementia so let's
not worry about the cancer he just
doesn't remember that he doesn't
Insanity uh and another good segue
speaking of Insanity John fetterman John
fetterman who is now a senator from
Pennsylvania wearing a hoodie who can
barely communicate he somehow beat Dr Oz
He is somehow part of the United States
government this whole thing is just
completely insane you may remember how
he opened his debate with Dr Oz by
saying good night to everybody what
qualifies you to be a U.S senator you
have 60 Seconds
hi good night everybody
I'm running to surf
he's a senator he's a senator where is
Dr Oz right now dog their eyes is pissed
pissed wherever he is
finally number one this was actually
quite easy for us to select number one
uh this probably was the moment the
political moment of the year because it
captures everything the insanity related
to gender and race and the political
pandering and the endless stupidity that
wokeness has uh just pushed upon all of
us this was during a katanji brown
Jackson Supreme Court nomination hearing
she was asked a question by Marcia
Blackburn senator from Tennessee and
well you remember can you provide a
definition for the word woman
can I provide a definition no yeah
I can't
you can't
not in this context I'm not a biology
meaning of the word woman is so unclear
and controversial that you can't give me
a definition senator in my work as a
judge what I do is I address disputes if
there's a dispute about a definition
people make arguments and I look at the
law and I decide so I'm not the fact
that you can't give me a straight answer
about something as fundamental as what a
woman is underscores the dangers of the
kind of progressive education that we
are hearing about it's just so perfect
it captured the whole damn thing and
then watching the media try to defend
katanji Brown and those Republicans were
asking gotcha questions and just being
mean and they're being racist by asking
her what a woman is it was just to me
that is the moment of the year I do have
very high hopes I I truly mean this and
I know I'm I'm a world weary optimist so
I'm not I'm not a blind-eyed Optimist a
blind-eyed Optimist would just be
running around going things are always
going to get better and they'll always
be better and we'll always be okay I'm
not that but I'm a world weary optimist
I believe that that the ark bends toward
Justice I believe that you can affect
the world you can make positive change I
really truly believe that I think you
have more power over your own life than
probably you believe you have I think
good things can happen I believe good
things happen to good people all of that
stuff uh and I think 2023 is going to be
a year of a bit of a sanity come back
that blueprint that I'm always talking
about which starts right here in Florida
I think that can be continued to be
exported it will not stop the other side
they will keep coming there will be
crazier stuff we're going to have we're
going to have toddler drag queen shows
like it's never going to stop uh but we
expose some of the nonsense we got a
little closer to truth this year and
hopefully if you watch this show you
laughed a little bit along the way and
on that note I once again want to wish
you guys a Happy Hanukkah Merry
Christmas a happy New Year and uh
we'll do it all again in 2023. see ya
good night everybody